[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents la
princesse nadine amouk et le prince lui
victime des sortilèges de merlin le
chanteur cherche une solution pour
retrouver leur apparence normale je peux
pas rester comme ça bouge pas on va les
vérifier des potiers je crois que c'est
fermé mardi
c'était bien on va quand même essayer
samedi ma mère est là rien n'a rien
[Musique]
mesdemoiselles
nous allons aujourd'hui aborder la leçon
27 chapitres 49/100 les doigts de ton et
maman sont en propre je compte sur votre
vigilance
le syndicat a toujours raison le seuil
du car ont toujours raison
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous savez pas
lire c'est fermé le mardi
il faut toujours obéir aux syndicats il
faut tout vous nous écoutez nous crottes
il ne faut pas oublier de payer ses
cotisations au syndicat nous pouvons
oublier de payer ses cotisations
syndicales colinot reset ces thèmes où
vous me reprenait tout ça plus fort s'il
vous plaît il ne faut pas pauline il ne
faut pas payer ses cotisations au
syndicat du silence on veut retrouver
notre apparence à vous voulez
transformer howie oui transformer nous
allez les filles le sont belles c'est
que ça pique
quarante deux donnerait pas qu'elle
l'ait fait exprès je les connais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]